mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs
bonjour la situation à la sncf
relevaient ce matin deux aspects d'une
part celui de la grève qui a été décidé
hier par la seule fédération cgt et
d'autre part l'aspect de la négociation
puisque la négociation vient de
s'engager ce matin à 9 heures entre
toutes les fédérations tous les
syndicats et la direction au siège de la
sncf
cette négociation a été interrompu à 11h
tout à l'heure françois legault est sur
place et nous allons l'appeler pour
qu'il nous fasse le point à vous dans
vos lecteurs je vous entends très bien
ce que vous entendez vous à 9h ce matin
effectivement la direction de la sncf et
les fédérations syndicales se
rencontraient au siège de la sncf rue
saint lazare à paris cela a duré deux
heures et c'était la dernière étape
d'une discussion
disons multeam discussions qui concerne
trois cent sept mille cheminots
exactement dernière étape assez
courageuse vous le savez puisque la cgt
avait organisé depuis 48 heures une
série de grèves dans de nombreuses
villes françaises
ces graines ont été suivies pour une
part les cheminots des charges
d'exploitation par 30 à 70 % des
personnels et chez les roulants les
agents de conduite par environ 60 à 80%
du personnel
ce matin on s'expliquait parfois un peu
durement
pourtant les ponts n'ont pas été rompus
et personne d'ailleurs autour de la
table de négociation ne soit l'hérault
en temps je pense que en fait on
pourrait aboutir peut-être un accord
vous dire vous préciser quand et à quel
moment c'est très difficile tout à
l'heure à 11h suspension de séance assez
ans reprendra à 14h30 et j'ai profité
cette suspension de séance pour
rencontrer deux syndicalistes d'abord
monsieur andré arganon cglu l'atmosphère
était un peu tendu en raison de la
situation que vous connaissez mais
ensuite
l'ensemble des organisations syndicales
a présenté des contre propositions par
rapport à celle faite par la sncf la
semaine dernière et la discussion s'est
engagée alors pour le moment nous ne
savons pas ce qu'il en ressortira
mais à partir du moment où nous avons eu
refus et qu'un nouveau rendez vous est
pris pour 14h30 ça veut dire que la
direction réfléchit aux contre
propositions des organisations
syndicales qui d'ailleurs sur des points
essentiels sont convergentes
monsieur demande à ce que l'on peut
penser que les points de vue entre les
deux parties vont à nouveau se
rapprocher cet après midi bien nous ne
sommes pas encore un rapprochement des
points de vue
la sncf a simplement fait accepter que
s'il devait y avoir un accord il se
limite à la période d'une année
pour le reste nous en sommes seulement
contre propositions des organisations et
le fait que la sncf n'ait pas opposé de
refus a priori mais a décidé de nous
demander une suspension pour examiner
les propositions faites nous pouvons
penser que nos propositions a priori ne
sont pas rejetés
la question que se posent les usagers
est la suivante quand le trafic peut-il
être établir sncf les bouteilles d'abord
le trafic n'est pas totalement
interrompue et ensuite l'évolution de la
situation dépendra de l'évolution des
discussions
pour l'instant nous n'en savons rien oui
c'est à dire françois go je crois que
l'on court quand même le risque d'une
grève générale si la discussion
d'aujourd'hui n'aboutit pas si la
discussion et non d'une aboutit pas
effectivement le conflit pourrait
s'étendre davantage
mais sans pouvoir sans être trop quand
il ya des champions à faire des
prévisions très exact c'est car c'est
très difficile je vous le répète on peut
penser tout de même que la discussion
aboutira et en fait il faut également
penser qu'elle se produira au finish
comme on dit merci françois cau votre
vrai georges valter tout à l'heure au
journal de 20 heures le 19 45 actualité
politique c'est samedi que s'ouvrira la
campagne électorale en vue du
renouvellement de la moitié des conseils
généraux à ce sujet un sondage que vient
de publier la sofres confirme que les
français sont très mal informés du rôle
des conseils généraux 68% des personnes
interrogées au cours de ce sondage ont
en effet déclaré mal connaître ces
assemblées départementales 49%
interrogés seulement en plus indiqué que
les conseillers généraux sont élus
directement au suffrage universel
enfin 54% les personnes n'ont pu citer
le nom du conseiller général de l'eure
quand est à noter que pour encourager la
participation à cette élection
la date d'ouverture de la pêche dans les
eaux de première catégorie a été avancé
au 28 février au lieu du 7 mars dès la
date initialement prévue
les nouvelles de l'étranger maintenant
c'est toujours du proche orient que l'on
se préoccupe et plus spécialement de la
jordanie le roi us 1 dans le pays est
déjà occupé à 70% par l'armée
israélienne se heurte aux mouvements de
résistance palestinienne vous le savez
il ya deux mouvements el fattah et le
fplp qui vous êtes à voir leur liberté
de mouvement quand roy et bien je
voudrais rester maître chez lui
la tension est vive nous enfermer coin
gérard ce bagne il ya des chars aux
tours de main oui en effet la crise
entre les commandos palestiniens et le
roi hussein rebondit à nouveau dans la
nuit des blindés de l'armée jordanienne
de l'armée royale jordanienne ou pris
position autour dahmane empêchant les
commandos palestiniens d'y entrer
empêchant même un convoi de l'armée
irakienne de traverser la ville par
ailleurs la radio de l'organisation
palestinienne la sifa la branche
militaire du fat appelé la population
jordanienne et tous les palestiniens
restés vigilants contre une possible
attaque surprise cet appel se terminer
par cette phrase le devoir des masses et
de garder en permanence le doigt sur la
gâchette des fusils mercredi dernier
déjà des incidents sanglants avaient
éclaté à amman faisant 30 morts à la
suite des mesures que vous l'êtes
habiter le roi hussein pour reprendre en
main les rênes de son pays qui lui
échappe et presque totalement le roi
hussein avait fait marche arrière et
annoncé que les mesures telles que le
désarmement des commandos dans les
villes ne serait pas appliquée les
négociations entre le roi et les
commandos palestiniens devait d'ailleurs
se dérouler dimanche prochain
et depuis 48 heures on parlait de plus
en plus d'une indication possible du roi
hussein
il y à des dissensions au sein du
cabinet jordanien également de l'armée
jordanienne
il est possible que des forces bédouine
favorable au rang 1 veille tenter de
reprendre la situation en main vous
allez voir d'ailleurs un film de cette
fameuse légion arabe composée surtout de
bédouin il
tout en ont été le soutien numéro un du
roi hussein mais à la suite de la guerre
des six jours avait été sérieusement
affaibli voici d'ailleurs ce que
déclarait après la crise de la semaine
dernière le roi hussein un journaliste
britannique est il exact de dire que la
jordanie était au bord de la guerre
civile la semaine dernière
je n'utiliserais pas le terme de guerre
civile mais plutôt disons que nous
aurions dû faire face à cette situation
si nous avions insisté à ce moment là
dans tous les cas il y aurait eu de
nombreuses victimes surtout dans les
régions urbaines et beaucoup d'innocents
aurait souffert mais c'est à fait
n'est-ce pas que la semaine dernière un
grand nombre d'officiers supérieurs
réflexion l'opinion alors comme vous
l'êtes agir contre le petit nombre
d'extrémistes
faisant partie des organisations de
colons en dehors ils ont dû accepter de
nombreux actes de provocation et en fait
avec un intervention personnelle
ils ont évité d'y répondre je crois que
certains éléments extrémistes ont fait
tout leur possible pour aggraver la
situation
alors que la fameuse légion arabe
s'affaiblissent et les commandos
palestiniens renforcer leurs rangs et
recevez en armement de plus en plus
important leur entraînement devenait
intensif ses commandos n'hésitez pas à
mettre en place des barrages sur toutes
les routes le roi hussein a toujours
voulu éviter un affrontement entre les
palestiniens et sa propre armée
affrontement qui serait certainement
sangles
mais que pense de la situation en
jordanie des capitales arabes
nous avons eu il ya quelques instants
seulement une liaison téléphonique avec
notre envoyé spécial permanent à
beyrouth perdre que nous avons écouté
tout est en suspens tout peut sortir de
la chaudière jordaniennes ou vous la
plus étrange mixture l'armée a repris
ces mesures de précaution autour de la
capitale dont toutes les grandes voies
d'accès sont coupées par des barrages
militaires appuyés par des blindés
de leur côté les organisations de
résistance et sont maintenant regroupés
au sein d'un commandement ont lancé un
appel au mât pour une vigilance accrue
le bruit court également fait des
officiers jordaniens dévoué aux
palestiniens auraient été écartés
va-t-on vers un nouvel affrontement en
général au nom tout ici la plupart des
personnes que j'ai vu ce matin ne pourra
dire que le roi malgré la pression de
l'entourage réseau stylo fedayin
envisage une quatrième épreuve de force
il pourrait être cette fois que très
sanglantes et décisive
mais je le répète tour est possible
aujourd'hui en jordanie
oui c'était bien andreu de beyrouth nous
passons maintenant la guerre du vietnam
qui semble s'étendre au laos en effet le
premier ministre laotien a déclaré ce
matin que le nord vietnam vient de
lancer une offensive générale dans le
nord de son pays
alliès américaine prête main forte aux
laotien pour contenir cette offensive
une statistique macabre à propos de
cette guerre du vietnam
en dix ans de guerre les pertes nord
vietnamienne évident quand on dépasse et
viennent de dépasser 600 mille morts le
chiffre exact est de 601 1315 tués
depuis le 1er janvier 1961 les pertes
américaines s'élève à plus de 40 mille
morts voilà pour la politique et pour la
guerre dans le domaine de la religion on
a noté ces jours derniers la rencontre à
londres entre le cardinal marty et le
chef de l'église anglicane
à ce sujet une correspondance de notre
bureau de beyrouth c'est à dire une
correspondance je crois de jacques
pirman ou plus exactement de notre ami
lefebvre
il y a dix ans cela aurait été
impossible
un pasteur protestant un évêque
orthodoxe
l'archevêque anglican de canterbury
l'archevêque catholique de paris
président ensemble un office religieux
cela s'est déroulé aujourd'hui en plein
coeur de londres à notre dame de france
c'était l'un des buts du cardinal marty
témoigner d'une foi commune sur cette
terre anglaise comme il me l'a expliqué
lui même
voyez je crois qu'il ne faut pas
seulement que ce soit les chefs des
églises les théologiens qui se
rencontrent pour discuter et qu'il faut
qu'il y ait des rencontres avec tout le
peuple des deux côtés des églises que
l'on apprenne à se connaître à se
comprendre
et puis aussi il ya des problèmes
communs qui se pose par exemple l'esprit
missionnaire
nous avons nos difficultés pastorale
dans le monde actuel c'est autant de
raisons qui font qu'il faut qu'il y ait
des contacts nombreux droits entre les
diverses églises
c'est un chemin qui peut appeler ainsi
se fait non seulement entre chefs mais
avec tout le peuple vers l'unité que
c'est dans ce sens que demain après
demain je vais visiter divers diocèses
anglais pour voir comment la pastorale
se réalise comme le peuple de l'église
anglicane nous accepte
commence à comprendre et à sa cheminée à
marcher avec nous certainement il faut
pas juger de jeu suivant notre
tempérament une autre civilisation notre
qualité française il faut juger aussi
suivante au peuple anglais ce qu'il est
ils sont dans une île on n'y sommes pas
nous et à la vie faut les juger tel
qu'il s'en saisit une interview du
cardinal marty par jean lefebvre qui se
trouve à londres pour nous toujours de
londres dieu s'est manifestée lui même
ahamada mouettes les âgé de 57 ans
depuis septembre 1968 dieu l'appeler
tous les soirs au téléphone pour lui
demander de l'argent
après lui avoir versé 588 milles francs
actuels donc 50 millions d'anciens
francs
madame whiteley a dû suspendre ses
versements car dieu avait été arrêté par
la police il s'agissait d'un escroc de
29 ans nommé john taylor qui a été
condamné aujourd'hui à quatre ans de
prison
comment en france pour une actualité qui
intéresse dunkerque et sa région un
reportage sur les travaux importants qui
sont effectués dans le port
dunkerque troisième port de france est à
un tournant de son histoire économique
le port avait prospéré à l'abri des
barrières douanières il se trouve
maintenant face à ses concurrents
européens envers à 140 km de là un
trafic cinq fois plus important et
rotterdam charge et décharge 11 fois le
tonnage de dunkerque pour lutter contre
ses rivaux dunkerque a deux atouts un
complexe sidérurgique au bord de l'eau
et un accès facile pour les grands
pétroliers minéralier 1,7 et funés
cuisse géante a été mise en chantier en
novembre 1966
aujourd'hui aller misano cet ouvrage de
365 mètres de long 50 mètres de large à
une profondeur de 21 mètres 50 ce qui
correspond à la hauteur d'un immeuble de
sept étages
il a fallu déplacer deux millions de
mètres cubes de sable et construire un
véritable barrage pour empêcher la merde
envahir les lieux de la construction
250 ouvriers ont travaillé pendant trois
ans les cluses a coûté 175 millions de
front des choses remarquables le devis
n'a pas été dépassé l'église est en
effet décidé signer pour permettre
l'accès les pilotes du port de vont
s'entraîner afin d'assimiler les
nouvelles manoeuvres et après des essais
assez long des pétroliers 225 mille
tonnes pourront franchir cette écluse
mais avant il faudra attendre neuf mois
afin que les clues soit misano une
performance est misano est effectué avec
deux mois d'avancé
nous remplissons le sas par
l'intermédiaire de quatre pompes qui
dans l'eau est déversée
directement dans le sas vous voyez avec
le mans ces quatre groupes qui déverse à
peu près de 1200 mètres cubes heures
dans le radier delécluse lécluse sera
totalement innover dans environ auxquels
quatre à cinq jours nous devons
surveiller cependant la montée de l'eau
de façon à assurer la stabilité des
ouvrages et quand pourra-t-on utilisé
pour la première fois sept écluses sept
écluses sera utilisé pour la première
fois à la fin de l'année 70
c'est à dire dans environ neuf mois
cette nouvelle écluse représente quelque
chose de très important pour l'avenir de
dunkerque puisque elle permet de doubler
d'un seul coup la capacité unitaire des
navires qui peuvent accéder aux corps
ceci permettant de faire entrer au port
des navires minéralier des navires
charbonnier 200 mille tonnes des navires
pétroliers atteignant également son
tonnage également des navires qui sans
atteindre le tonnage de 100 mille tonnes
et accéderont par les dimension
horizontale seuls qui peuvent être
admises à l'heure actuelle par les
cluses d'activer jacqueline nous fêtons
aujourd'hui un anniversaire savez-vous
de l'anniversaire de qui il s'agit non
non c'est celui des deux fameux jumeaux
bruno est là qu'ils sont nés à munich il
ya un an ils sont en parfaite santé
comme vous le voyez sur cette photo et
ils ont fait honneur à leur gâteau
d'anniversaire
tous nos voeux à la famille vous voyez
ce sont des petits or en goûtant il se
peut très bien quelles sont les
nouvelles
et bien notre première page magazine
sera destiné aux télés philatélistes aux
philatélistes en tout cas avec
l'émission de jacqueline koror quoi de
neuf cette semaine jacqueline la
philatélie et la couture sont associés
en quoi et bien la philatélie inspire la
couture à preuve c'est joli bouton
décorer avec notamment un usage courant
que nous élégant et élégante pour
motards bord et même s'il ne distingue
pas une crs d'une marianne comme quoi
voyez-vous la philatélie mène à tout
même à la fantaisie
mais soyons sérieux et parlant sport je
vous le disais la philatélie mainate ou
entendez par là qu'elle traite de tous
les sujets les prochains championnats du
monde de handball vont se dérouler sur
notre sol et cet événement sportif
méritait un timbre qui sera émis samedi
et dimanche prochain est mise en vente
anticipée au gymnase de la porte de
chouettes à l'occasion exposition
philatélique premier jour également les
21 et 22 février et sur le même sujet
d'un timbre andorran à
andorre-la-vieille ce thème vous pourrez
vous le procurer à partir du 23 février
au bureau de la recette principale de
perpignan est également au guichet
philatélique de paris marseille lyon
bordeaux et strasbourg comme nous vers
un passé tout proche celui de ces jours
derniers kibir plusieurs expositions
philatéliques avignon section
philatélique des jeunes et de la culture
présentait sa quatrième exposition à la
maison du tourisme
le thème général en était le folklore et
plus particulièrement le folklore
provençal à travers timbre-poste écarte
maximum chez chip réputé chez trésors
artistiques ces hommes célèbres ces
personnages légendaires étaient
également exposées quelques autres
thématiques dont celle sur les sports
d'été et d'hiver
une manifestation organisée par des
jeunes dont l'effort ne peut être
qu'encouragés nous voici maintenant dans
la région parisienne à pantin dont la
société philatélique fêter sa dixième
année très belle sélection de poste
aérienne avec précurseurs dont cette
lettre
transporté par le neptune à destination
de la belgique et se plie qui devaient
être acheminés par fuzer postale mais
l'expérience fut interrompue par ordre
du ministère de l'intérieur
ici les numéros heide de la poste
aérienne française les mêmes sur l'être
là les célèbres surcharge ile de france
qui plus est sur une lettre catapulté du
paquebot
plus loin les timbres de 1932
l'exposition internationale de paris
avec perforation à l'envers et retourné
des épreuves de luxe du 50 francs de
1936 sans oublier la vedette de cette
série le 50 francs bührle rose pour en
arriver aux séries modernes était aussi
présenté des collections spécialisées
concernant les marques maritime cachet
de ligne marc paquebot des collections
de carnets des études de certains baux
moderne dont ceux de la dernière guerre
cachée de dunkerque de l'occupation
allemande timbre de la chambre de
commerce de saint nazaire
enfin timbre de la libération un
ensemble éclectique qui méritait bien
une visite
je vous rappellerai l'exposition
napoléon 1er et la poste qui continue
d'attirer de très nombreuses à mater au
musée postal de paris attention c'est
parce fermeront le 28 février
ce calme relatif en ce qui concerne les
manifestations s'explique très bien
puisque la journée nationale du timbre
approche et que celle ci est préparée
dans 86 villes de france de m'asseoir 20
février attention sera retiré de la
bande le tabra un franc représentant un
bas relief de la cathédrale d'amiens de
naissance celle du club philatélique de
l'amicale des anciens parachutistes et
des anciens commando de la france libre
et celle de l'amicale philatélique
france israël du côté des ventes nous
est signalée celle qui se déroulera les
25 26 et 27 février aux enchères à
l'hôtel drouot dispersion d'une très
belle collection de france et bien
maintenant coup d'oeil sur les dernières
nouveautés étrangères pour commencer
voici une très jolie série émises par
les îles vierges
série qui séduira tous ceux d'entre vous
qui ont choisi pour thème de collection
la marine et plus particulièrement les
embarcations à travers les âges pour nos
pages zoologie ces poissons du honduras
britannique
ces insectes des îles malawi et ses
oiseaux du vietnam le 6 février dernier
eut lieu la conversion des bermudes au
système décimal ce qui nous vaut des
surcharges hanssens et en dollars sur
les timbres de la série courante et mise
en monnaie anglaise
l'australie vient d'adopter pour ces
chemins de fer entre sydney et perth
notamment l'écartement standard des voix
art architecture a eu avec cette pagode
laotienne de 26 à kate est cette église
congolaise de ligne solo dans les
distributeurs automatiques de suède les
usagers pourront se procurer un nouveau
carnet de timbres poste représentant des
objets d'art forget voici des
instruments de musique de l'est africain
30 centimes le marimba de tanzanie 70
centimes la madinda d'ouganda 1.50
le zoo mari de francs 50 l'a22 du kenya
amis philatélistes au revoir à jeudi
prochain
l'industrie française du jouet a une
place très enviable sur le marché
mondial une société des amis du jouet
est en train de se constituer première
opération ouvrir un musée du jouet un
reportage de france vérité l'industrie
française du jouet arrive au cinquième
rang dans le monde avec 680 millions de
chiffre d'affaires à l'étranger on
compte des centaines de musée du jouet
en effet les jouets peuvent revêtir
incontestablement un intérêt historique
psychologiques sociologiques par le
relation avec la religion l'art la
médecine l'éducation en france les
études récentes sur ce sujet reste très
peu nombreuses c'est pourquoi c'est
créer une société des amis du jouet dont
l'un des but est justement la création
d'un musée du jouet
madame ravec magnard conservateur en
chef du musée d'histoire de l'éducation
nous parle de l'intérêt
tel projet je crois qu'à musée du jouet
a beaucoup d'intérêt d'abord parce que
la france est le seul pays d'europe à
n'avoir pas de musée du jouet c'est une
lacune à mon avis regrettable un musée
de la nacre froid musée de la chasse et
du papier au musée du jouet s'impose
ensuite parce que le jouet est le reflet
de toutes les civilisations et que par
exemple les enfants arabes jouent
quelque chose et joue à construire un
aqueduc parce que l'eau est pour eux une
question de toute première nécessité les
jeux et les jouets à travers les siècles
ont reflété de très près l'actualité et
on a des jeux pour et contre dreyfus et
enfin parce que je pense qu'un musée du
jouet pour y recueillir quantité de
jouets qui s'en vont maintenant à
l'étranger et je trouve cette processus
infiniment regrettable étant donné que
les joueurs français par leur beauté par
leur variété par leur nombre constitue
véritablement une partie de notre
patrimoine
ce musée en forme de jeux de
construction fait de matériaux de
couleurs serait situé dans l'île de la
jatte tout près de paris conçu en
collaboration avec le conseil
international des musées
il serait un véritable centre de culture
vivent avec non seulement des galeries
d'exposition certaines permanente et
d'autres temporaire mais aussi une salle
d'animation où les enfants pourraient
créer des jouets une phonothèque une
cinémathèque un centre de documentation
pour terminer madame rabec manière nous
présente quelques jouets d'un intérêt
particulier
voici un excellent exemple de ces jeux
éducatifs qui furent répandue déjà
l'ancien grèce et dont on attribue à
tort
l'invention au 20e siècle il s'agit ici
d'un jeu doit à 63 cases qui raconte le
l'histoire de la monarchie française
depuis les origines jusqu'à la rentrée
de vue 18 à paris en 1814 tout au long
du jeu doit on rappelle les hauts faits
des différents rois de france c'est au
fait qu'ils sont d'ailleurs assez
curieusement choisi par exemple voici
philippe le bel qui fait brûler
les templiers en 13 114 le philips 5le
l'on suit ainsi noble exor et fait
griller vifs les juifs comme
empoisonneurs vous avez ici une
représentation d'une classe au temps de
louis philippe celle ci particulièrement
intéressante parce que elles donnent une
idée de ce qu'était une école faire 1830
la fin de classe tout simplement la
chambre de l'instituteur dont vous voyez
le vit au fond se lit il a jugé une
petite valise qui doit contenir quelques
pour effet le poil qui est chauffé au
bois
c'est le temps où chaque écolier poste à
l'école sa bûche pour que la classe
puisse être chauffé le tambour est un
souvenir du premier empire
on appelle les enfants pour rentrer en
classe au son du tambour
une petite idée aussi de ce qui était
les positions celle ci est très anodines
ces bonnets d'âne pour c'est quelquefois
des inscriptions à fermente and
rapporteur voleurs etc et les petites
filles dans certaines écoles étaient
chargés de bronzer au point de croix des
inscriptions on mettait sur les bonnets
d'âne michel tardieu peut-on jouer en
bourse aujourd'hui
retour aux pulsions ça veut surprise
maintenu en panne en scène s'il faut je
pense vous arrivez dans un bois
infernale vous pouvez arrêter de taper à
la machine s'il vous plaît jacqueline
dans ce conte à l'antenne c'est une
séance d'effritement encore aujourd'hui
la bourse de paris et ce n'est pas une
surprise parce que c'est la liquidation
c'est à dire que tous les gens qui ont
acheté à terme doivent aujourd'hui payer
les titres qui nous ont acheté ou les
revend et beaucoup les roseaux et d'une
liquidation à l'autre de la liquidation
de janvier à celle de février est bien
la bourse a baissé elle a baissé de je
ne sais pas combien exactement nous
serons demain mais je pense d'après
l'avis de certains professionnels que la
baisse est de l'ordre de 4 à 5 %
l'or en revanche aujourd'hui est plus
résistant qui hier aussi bien sur le
lingot que sur les pièces on regagne un
petit peu de terrain
et pourtant la guerre de l'or continue
le président nixon hier a affirmé que
l'or devait jouer un rôle de moins en
moins grand sur le plan monétaire est
content
il fallait donner de l'extension aux
droits de tirage spéciaux vous savez ce
qu'on appelle les dts leurs papiers pour
que le dollar soit plus à son aise et le
métal jaune fait parler de lui fait
parler de lui parce que le président
nixon donc confirme qu'il veut sa
disparition progressive
et d'autre part parce que la banque de
nos fiches de mme berger mâle est la
banque française l'a connue a publié
récemment une note intitulée la baisse
une note sur la baisse de l'or intitulé
mouvement en profondeur ou péripéties
conjoncturelle d'autre part les grands
courtiers anglais ont eux aussi publié
toute une série de notes ces derniers
mois seul problème de l'or et ce matin
l'agencé économique et financière
reprend un article de la revue
économique franco suisse rédigé par le
directeur de la banque nationale suisse
monsieur max et bien comment sont fait
doubler par le point de vue du banquier
suisse
et il constate d'abord que l'or
constitue toujours la majeure partie des
réserves monétaires détenus dans le
monde
il constate aussi que le métal jaune est
la seule monnaie que les banques
centrales accepte en période de guerre
ou de crise grave
et il ajoute que personne ne change ne
songe sérieusement à son avis a
démonétisé le métal comme la plupart de
ses confrères le banquier suisse se
prononce sans ambages pour un système
proche de celui de l'étalon or qui lui
paraît le plus réaliste et il constate
que la création des droits de tirage
spéciaux sur les faits me permets
simplement aux états unis de mieux
défendre leurs stocks d'or sans les
obliger à reprendre rapidement des
mesures pour équilibrer leur balance des
paiements il dit que si ces mesures sont
pas prises et bien washington étonnera
de plus en plus son hégémonie politique
et économique sur le monde entre la
banque français de nos fiches de berger
reprend un peu le même argument et
constate que c'est le poids politique
des états unis qui rejouent le rôle
déterminant dans le prix de l'or selon
de neuf lycées parce que les pays
européens ont peur les états unis et ne
peuvent résister à leur pression
politique qu'il renonce à transformer
leurs dollars en or et comme rien ne
laisse prévoir une modification
prochaine des rapports de force entre
les états unis et l'europe n'affiche un
berger mâle est conclu qu'il y a peu de
chances que le prix lors se modifie
sensiblement dans
l'année qui vient il ya cependant un cas
où ce prix pour augmenter disent des
experts de nos fiches sont des rejets
c'est celui où une monnaie européenne on
commencerait à faire ce qu'a fait le
mari c'est à dire à donner des signes de
surpuissance qui pourrait aboutir à sa
réévaluation
alors là dans la période qui précédait
cette évaluation l'or pourrait bien sûr
remontée et les experts de la banque dit
cette hausse de l'or qui pourrait
arriver peut-être dans trois ou quatre
ans bien serait de l'ordre de 20 à 20 %
il enchaîne en disant attendent pas
quatre ans pour une hausse du métal de
20 25 % ce n'est pas intéressant puisque
les taux d'intérêt à l'heure actuelle
sont de l'ordre de 10 % l'an que donc
que les détenteurs de métal perdent un
tel avantage en intérêts je ne sais pas
si ce raisonnement des experts de
monsieur bergé est très bon parce que je
ne crois pas que ce soit la même
clientèle qui thésaurisent des journées
et des lingots et celle qui a des
capitaux suffisamment important pour
obtenir du 10 % l'an de rémunération
mais n'ont d'ailleurs si cette banque
offre du 10 % à sa clientèle donc je ne
suis pas tout à fait sûr que cet
argument des taux d'intérêts 10% puisse
suffire à dissuader les gens qui gardent
de l'or si on leur dit en même temps
qu'il y aura une possibilité de hausse
dans les années qui viennent mais
courtier anglais eux font un
raisonnement un petit peu différent ils
disent que la demande industrielle de
métal jaune est tellement importante
qu'elle est plus grande que la
production annuelle est dit donc que
aussi croit à une hausse du métal dans
les quatre ou cinq ans qui viennent
mais quand on considère cette
affirmation des courtiers hand mais il
ne faut pas oublier quand même que le
stock d'or détenues par les particuliers
dans le monde entier représente à peu
près 13 ans de production et quand il ya
un stop pareil eh bien il est toujours
dangereux de spéculer à la hausse sur le
produit en question
ceci dit lorsque leur a probablement
parlé encore très longtemps de lui et
les américains ont beau affirmer qu'il
ne se soucie pas du métal qu'il
considère que c'est une marchandise
absolument comme les autres il est très
peu probable que ça démonétisation
arrive rapidement
je me garderais bien d'en tirer des
conclusions sur le plan
déplacement parce que en matière d'or
tout le monde réagit de façon un petit
peu passionnel les fanatiques de l'or
resteront des fanatiques de l'or et ceux
qui pensent que c'est un mauvais
placement pour tyr au mur on de jouer
l'or ou gémonies ceci dit pour terminer
sur des informations plus claires et
plus net je vous dirais que peugeot
lance à ce moment un emprunt de 200
millions de francs qui rapportent de 8
75% emprunt qui servira à couvrir les
financements des investissements pour
les cinq ans à venir que réalise cette
société automobile et qui permettra
notamment de porter la production de
peugeot de 490 milles à 800 mille
véhicules en 1975 les demandes de
financement sur le marché financier en
ce moment sont très importantes il ya
l'emprunt des scènes il ya l'entrain
peugeot on parle d'une augmentation de
capital de la financière de paris des
pays bas il faut souhaiter parce que je
crois que c'est l'intérêt tout le monde
que toutes ces demandes faites sur le
marché financier et bien obtiennent une
réponse ici la bourse de paris à vous
les studios
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs télé
midi est maintenant terminée au revoir à
demain